the fastest way to achieve your goals is
to model the people who've already
achieved the same goals that you have
model success success excludes the
famous expression and it's true I
learned this lesson first when I was 20
years old out of desperation where I was
making no money and struggling and I
quit on my business partner I quit you
know I can't keep going I quit and I
modeled Bill Gates I just asked myself
who has done this before you know in
modeling Bill Gates and how he started
Microsoft that's what saved my business
and allowed me to keep going I wish I
had somebody guide me or Mentor me and
it's a very basic idea model success it
really just came out of moment of
desperation where I'm at my parents home
prying my face off because I just quit
on this business that I cared about I
didn't want to fail but I felt there was
no option I just felt overwhelmed
frustrated it just was not working out
and it was only in that absolute moment
of Crisis I thought maybe somebody else
has done this before we're up until that
point I felt like I had to come up with
every idea myself and nothing would seem
to be working and it wasn't until I
asked that question then I found Bill
Gates and how he started Microsoft and
that's what started turning the company
around wanna store get a mentor hey it's
Nina
cars probably because you're the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of much more and you
get that Push by surround yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best my husband Evan Carmichael
and learn the fastest way to achieve the
goal you set enjoy
whatever problem you're facing right now
it's been addressed many many many many
times by many many many many many many
successful people
your job becomes to find out who they
are and to go back and study how they
how they solve that problem and it's
really important to figure out how they
solve the exact problem that you're
struggling with right now so what I told
myself when I was looking at Bill Gates
was
I don't care how Bill Gates makes an
extra million dollars right now how did
he get started how do you go from zero
to one what was the thing that that
built this company up and for all these
people the bigger they are the easier it
is to research their story Bill Gates
only came to mind because I had a
software company and I just said who's
built a software company it was not
even that structured or thought out or
in depth or or you know in detail
he was the first guy that I thought of
that had a software company Bill Gates
Microsoft how do you do it that was it
and in looking at the story I found out
that Microsoft built their business
through Partnerships
and their big deal came when they made a
partnership with IBM and IBM at the time
was the biggest computer manufacturer on
the planet so the deal was every IBM
that was shipped every computer that was
shipped from the biggest computer
manufacturer in the world had Microsoft
software on it it was a huge deal that
blew up the company and that was pretty
easy to find right the transitional
moment in the company
it's like wow okay Partnerships that's
interesting I mean we can do that but
Microsoft was already a seven million
dollar company when they made that deal
now 7 million was nothing compared to
whether they would go on to be right
billions and billions of dollars but
it was seven million dollars it was
still more than what I had
right seven million dollars felt like a
giant company compared to me making 300
bucks a month right so
the next layer is to dig a Little Deeper
not just their big break which is
important but how did they get started
like how did they get to The Big Break
is really valuable it's really helpful
to figure out and again the bigger the
person is that you're modeling the
easier it is to find the content you
just might have to dig you might have to
go read biographies read articles read
interviews watch videos to figure out
those early Parts not their just their
upbringing but what were the things that
they did that led to the big
breakthrough not just what the big
breakthrough was big breakthrough is
super important but the steps that led
to the brick big breakthrough even more
important if you're at the beginning
getting started so Microsoft big
breakthrough was the IBM deal they're
already seven million dollar company how
did they get to become a seven million
dollar company that was the million
dollar question maybe the seven million
dollar question and it was still through
Partnerships
so what Microsoft did was they had
software and they looked at any hardware
that existed
that needed software for it
and they would go in and Pitch their
software their first deal was with the
mitz Altair and
the mid-tal tear was a was a piece of
hardware and it was featured on on the
cover of uh of their magazine that was
the big magazine for the computer
industry at the time and they needed
software and Bill Gates and uh called
them up with his partner Paul Allen and
said hey we've got software for the
mid-saltier that you can use that will
make it a lot more valuable valuable to
people and they didn't even have it
built yet
on the on the on the plane ride over to
go meet the company Bill Gates was
finishing up the code to go
program and they hope that it would work
and luckily it did when they when they
had the meeting uh so I don't I don't
necessarily like that part of lying that
you've got something but it's
interesting to know how he did it the
the boldness the the willingness to
reach out and say hey I've got something
that can help you were things that I
really struggled with as a 19 year old
entrepreneur believing that what I had
was great then I could really solve big
problems where Bill Gates was saying
yeah we got this even though he didn't
have it yet and he wrote it on the plane
on the on the way over right but it was
still through Partnerships
and anytime Microsoft was entering
something new they they found
Partnerships and so I applied that
strategy to me and I started looking for
who can who can we partner with not like
a business partner where they own a
piece of our company but who can we
partner with that is a distribution deal
and the first uh company that I
made a deal with was out of the UK and
we had a arrangement for them to
represent us in the UK and a couple of
the markets in Europe where they would
be Distributing our product and we made
an exclusive deal so that anytime we got
a lead from those markets it would go to
them and they would be doing their own
marketing promotion as well and in
exchange for that exclusive partnership
they would pay us thirteen and a half
thousand dollars up front
and I remember I was I was so scared to
ask for that it felt like a giant number
what if they said no this big potential
deal and uh and they said yes they said
yes and we had we had money in our bank
account
for the first time which was wild and
crazy and
that was a fantastic deal for us and
more important is it it said it gave us
hope which is maybe important to give us
momentum which is Mega important and it
gave us a model to keep following and so
what I what I ended up doing after which
was let's go get more partnership deals
let's go get more partnership deals and
the people who ended up buying us was
basically a partnership deal so instead
of partnering with our company they just
bought the whole business
and that's how we exited all because of
modeling Bill Gates when I quit on my
company so whatever
problem you're facing personal or
business
people have solved it humans have been
around for a long time
somebody has solved this problem you do
not have to be a genius and come up with
every new idea yourself can your
creativity and love and Panache help yes
of course
but you don't have to have the seed for
every great idea
and chances are
the problem that you're facing right now
there's an answer
10 minutes away from you from a YouTube
video that's that's online from a book
from a podcast from an interview there's
an answer out there for you and if you
just default the same I'm going to model
success I'm going to find the people
who've done this and exactly how they
solve that specific problem that you're
facing right now not how they're living
their life right now but how do they get
over the hurdle that you're facing when
you can dig deep and find those answers
and again the bigger the person is
the more accessible the content is
if you want to learn about Bill Gates's
early life or Steve Jobs's early life or
Oprah Winfrey's early life or whoever it
is it's accessible it's there you can
find this stuff
and it gives you the hope
that it's possible for you and it gives
you the specific strategies that you can
use to apply to your life right now so
you can start seeing results
success leaves Clues
whatever problem you've got
gold model success rule number two push
yourself to the extreme people don't
push themselves to the extreme
they just don't
it's because it's too hard it's too
crazy hard that you're not likely to do
it on your own and so I think when those
opportunities come learning to embrace
them learning to take them on learning
to say this is my chance to show myself
in the world what I am made of this is
my chance
but is it still your limit so let me
give you a couple examples this morning
I woke up and I didn't have a lot of
sleep I went to bed at three something
last night I woke up at 7 20 this
morning I turned off the alarm but still
woke up at 7 20. force a habit and I'm
not on a lot of sleep and I need to make
a bunch of videos for you guys and I
want to bring my best and I put pressure
on myself that every video needs to be
my best I want it to be better I want to
grow I don't want to just do the same
thing over and over and over again
but it's a challenge and so it's easy to
say oh I'm so tired I don't have energy
I wish I slept more I remember an excuse
after excuse but no I'm gonna go do it
and here I am and I've made I don't know
how many videos are ready today I'm
closing in on finishing up and I still
have energy and I'm pumped for how it
went and in the story I'm telling myself
is I'm awesome like I had very little
sleep it's not how I want to be living
every day but when that happens what do
you do how do you stand up how do you
show yourself What You're Made Of
but even that is not the biggest extreme
you know like I feel like I'm capable of
way more my tour
was the most that I'd ever pushed myself
not just mentally not just facing fears
but physically physically pushing myself
where I broke my neck in two spots
um I had a concussion I've never had a
concussion before I was wild
don't wish anybody if you haven't
experienced it yet uh had three Staples
in my head I compressed my spine it was
brutal
and I had to cancel my event in Denver
where I was because it was that night
and then the next one was going to be in
Kansas City this is what I wore for for
60 days I wore these and I took them off
for 10 minutes a day
60 days right like this is what I made
it this is what I'm capable of I'm
complaining about having four hours
sleep I did I have my neck broken and
continued on my tour
across the U.S for 30 more days and
another 30 days here in Toronto
seeing entrepreneurs sitting in pain at
the front of the room with ice packs and
pillows and not quitting and going home
even though I was in massive pain like
this is who I am and I'm complaining
about not having sleep the night before
right like perspective the greatest
point on the tour for me was in Kansas
city was my next stop we refunded
everybody the money because I wasn't
going to be able to go for three hours
but I said hey we already booked this
hotel venue
you guys already booked your night off
why don't you just come out anyway just
come on out and I'll go for an hour and
take pictures and say hi and just show
some Kansas City love
and I showed up and we went for an hour
and a half and then my wife pulled me
off
because my lips are starting to get dry
because I wasn't being able to you know
answer questions at Clues I'd like
because I was still suffering from the
concussion you know the the neck pain is
one thing
that's just sitting still I can't do
anything about it but the concussion
you're not supposed to think you're not
supposed to have conversations and it
makes the recovery worse
and so she's she was watching me like a
hawk the whole night she's watching me
and then she sees me start the Fate he's
like okay that's it I gotta take Evan
home quick pictures and we gotta go
I've never been pulled off a stage
before
never for like for sucking or definitely
for a physical issue never never it's
never happened
this was me at my physical limit
that was it I was done I had actually
nothing left like somebody had to come
and say you are done
fast right
I mean it sucked but at the same time
it's like man this is it I actually I
got to the edge I got to the physical
limitation I can't go anymore I'm being
told I need to step down and there's
something so amazing that you feel about
yourself that you were able to go that
far now you don't want to do that every
day you want to take care of your health
of course of course of course don't
don't do stupid things
and at the same time the pride
the feeling of Awesomeness
that you hit that Mark I can't explain
so I started telling the people around
me my wife my agent the people on the
tour that were planning the 2020 tour
and it's not going to be as good
this will be great we're gonna hit 23
cities 90 days East Coast Texas Mexico
you know Montreal it's going to be fun
but it won't be as good because I'm not
going to break my neck
wait I'm not gonna hit I'm not gonna
forcefully go break my neck just because
right that's that that's stupid don't do
that don't don't don't go do that just
because and so I'm not gonna face the
same challenge
and so the point is also have a great
time it'll still be amazing but what we
went through what I had to go through in
2019 this year is
yes foundational like
I'm gonna remember this forever this is
who I am this this this is who I am
not the guy who
thinks that four hours sleep and making
some videos is a big deal right it just
resets who you are and reminds you if
you step up to the challenge of what
you're capable of
and so
the point of this rant for today is not
to say go and do something crazy and and
to risk your life and to put yourself in
Humble situations I'm not saying that
I'm saying that those things are coming
for you anyway
life is coming for you you're going to
face massive adversities massive
difficulties it's coming
you don't have to seek it out this is
coming all on its own
how you choose to handle it
that becomes defining for you either way
you're going to be defined by it you're
going to be the person who succumbs to
it who doesn't stand up who feels small
who feels insignificant or you're going
to be the person who Rises to the
challenge
who steps up to the plate who even if
you don't get the result right I got
pulled off of the Kansas City stage even
if you don't get the result you gave it
your best and they're such an amazing
feeling of Pride and gratitude and and
just self-love when you know that you
actually gave everything that you had
and so the next time you get faced with
that kind of challenge that comes to you
make the decision that will make you
proud and tell yourself this is the best
this is my chance to show myself and the
world just exactly who I am and what I'm
made of also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there the
difference between outstanding and
average is what you do when it gets hard
people with an average mindset only do
things when it's easy because it's easy
anyone can do it but Life Is Coming For
You setbacks they're coming for you and
that's what separates the average from
the outstanding your goals they don't
count until it's hard so I had a new guy
on my team who's writing to me to say
Evan it's super important this is urgent
I need help with my schedule I'm just
not seeing consistent I'm not staying on
my goals I know what I want to get done
for you but also for my life and and
it's not unless it's some deadline or
you're on me it's not happening I'm not
consistent on it how do how do I get
going how do I stay consistent
and so we work together through the
schedule and we created his calendar and
say what are your goals and put it in
your calendar and how do you want each
day to go and he plotted out his
Saturday to Sunday you know the whole
week and then I asked him okay now put
in your morning routine what do you want
to do every day right so we plotted that
into his calendar now he's got this
weekly schedule of what he's gonna do
every morning and then every day doing
different things and how he wants his
ideal life to go awesome
and then I told him what really mattered
like this is great your actions map to
your Ambitions really important
but following through in your calendar
doesn't count until it's hard
maybe maybe today is going to be easy
for you maybe tomorrow's easy for you
because we talked because you're
motivated because you're inspired it's
like yeah yeah I'm gonna go do it
awesome what happens when you don't
sleep well what happens when something
happens in your family what happens when
the website crashes what happens when
something happens what happens when
you've lost some motivation energy what
happens when you get some bad news what
happens what do you do this is where
most people crumble
this is where most people as soon as
this one little tiny thing that
interrupts them they're gone they fall
off their entire schedule and routine
your goals suddenly don't matter anymore
you don't think they're possible
your goals don't count until they're
hard that's what I told them I said
listen listen to me
this is a great plan
that life that you wrote that's a great
life what you wrote down on your
calendar that's a great life for you
that's what you want
imagine if you did that every day for
the next year how different would your
life look like one year from today if
you were consistent on staying like oh
yeah yeah amazing I mean great
doesn't count until it's hard none of
this matters until it's hard life is
coming for you get ready
and what I want him and I want you to
realize is that
you need to expect it
because you're working your calendar and
it's great and here we go we're getting
our getting our objectives and going for
our goals and then when something hits
Us in the face you're surprised by it
you're shocked and then you fall off
course don't be surprised expect it
expected difficulty expect the road bump
expect somebody to punch you in the face
like expected it's coming
and this is your chance to be
outstanding
because everybody else is going to be
average and your average friends will
let you off the hook your average Trends
will tell you it's okay don't worry
about it
uh of course like this thing happened of
course no that's not acceptable
not if you want to be outstanding
you take that setback and use it as fuel
like this is it this is the chance this
thing happened now this is my chance to
show myself in the world what I'm made
of let's go your goals don't count until
they're hard so if you're having a hard
time staying consistent on your goals
I'm going to give you a three-step
process that I think will help step
number one is what I call Flex the X I
have this calendar at some point I need
to I need to I need to print this off or
sell it or something but it takes at
least 18 days for you to build a habit
between 18 and 254 days of consecutive
action build a habit so what I do is I
have this calendar it's just it's just
an 18 day calendar that I call Flex the
X and what I mean by that is you're
making an X for every day right don't
break the chain every single day you
want to put a neck so right now I'm
doing uh this is something with my wife
so every morning we do a morning breath
hug so
we'll hug each other and then we think
this is wild we sink sink your breath if
you're with somebody if you have a
husband or wife or boyfriend girlfriend
try this it's crazy you hug them and
then you go Heart to Heart right and
then you you breathe in together and out
together take a deep breath in deep
breath out deep breath in deep breath
out together you sink it it's crazy
connection anyway we do that every
morning and then in the evening it's uh
we share three wins so as we walk the
dogs we walk the dogs or we got one here
here's one this is Tristana hello
Tristana
good girl okay go back
we walk the dogs
and we share three wins what are your
three wins from today what happened so
she shares her three wins I share my
three wins and every time that I do it
then we
cross off an X and I've got what four
five one two three four five five more
days left I'm here to finish this off so
anytime I'm trying to build a new habit
I pulled out the flexi X calendar
whether you use the exact one that I
have here or you just draw 18 boxes and
you just start checking them off or take
out a calendar you Flex the X because as
you're doing something for 18 days you
start to actually now start training
that habit and so you look at it and say
here's what I want to work on those are
two new habits I want to build so every
day we're going to do it this this piece
of paper is visible to me it's right by
my nightstand usually in my bedroom and
it's a reminder oh I gotta do it I gotta
do it let's go let's Nina hug let's go
come on
foreign
Flex the X step number two is remind
yourself that it doesn't count until
it's hard that sentence that I told the
person on my team it's what I tell
myself that that it's coming that the
challenges are coming even if you want
to put it on your flexi X calendar right
just put it here it doesn't maybe I
should just put it on there it doesn't
count until it's hard
remind myself as a reminder for you guys
it doesn't count till it's hard it
reminds yourself that it's coming so
that when it comes when you're tired
even for me this morning uh I was up
late right I was up till three o'clock
last night and I woke up at seven just
before 7 30 7 20. you got to take these
guys out so not on a lot of sleep four
and a half hours is not typical for me
and I've got to make a whole bunch of
videos today and the espresso ones take
the most time energy effort you know
impact thought consideration because I
want to bring my best to you guys
and so it's easy to say oh I only slept
four and a half hours what am I gonna do
I gotta make these videos this suck no
it doesn't count until it's hard right
that's that's literally how it happens
as soon as the complaints or
insecurities or fears or excuses come in
you you snap it say it doesn't count
these goals don't count until it's hard
let's go remind yourself daily and then
step number three is celebrate and I
don't think I do an even good enough job
on this but when we're done this like 18
days like hey celebrate right just just
recognize that you did something special
and whether whether that's
you're gonna go out for dinner or you're
gonna do something to actually celebrate
or put on a song or dance or whatever
just just to make yourself feel like you
do hard things and you're growing and
you can stay consistent and you don't
give up and you don't procrastinate and
you move forward towards your goals and
just making yourself feel like what you
do matters and that you can do difficult
things and the more that you take on
these kinds of many tasks and challenges
the more they'll make you feel like you
can take a bigger step and the next time
an even bigger step by the next time an
even bigger step that celebration
reinforces how much of an awesome person
you are I think that's the biggest game
it's the inside game it's not what your
parents think of you or your friends or
your husband or wife it's you like what
do you think about you do you think
you're awesome because if you think
you're awesome I guarantee you're gonna
do awesome things if you think that you
suck as a human
you're not going to rule number four
Focus the problem isn't that you're not
a genius that you're not talented that
you don't have wisdom and abilities and
resourcefulness and that you're not
Michael Jordan that's not the problem
the problem is you're not focused you're
not doing the things that you need to do
I just came back from video marketing
World in Dallas and I was being asked
about where to spend the time Which
social media sites to spend time on and
I think this is a classic example of
where entrepreneurs fail is you're
trying to do everything and as a result
you suck everywhere and feel burnt out
tapped out and not building momentum if
you get to the end of a week
and you feel like you worked your face
off but you look back what did I get
done if that's how you're ending a week
you worked hard and feel like what did I
get done you're not focused you're
switching between tasks too much
instead of having all of these social
media sites at the same time pick one
and crush it
I quoted Andrew Carnegie at my event at
my speech my favorite quote from him is
put all your eggs in one basket and then
watch that basket everybody's saying
diversify diversify diversify have 18
different multiple streams of income
look at the people who are who are a
one-person show with 18 streams of
income they're making no money
you're making ten dollars a month from
this and 25 a month from that and 18
cents from this you're not making money
now as you build and scale and grow and
you have a team like I do I've got 24
people on my team okay great now it
might be time to diversify but as a solo
person you can't do everything yourself
and you are a genius you have Michael
Jordan level Talent at something and
that's what you need to find and that's
where you need to spend as much time as
possible on until you're making money
you can invest back into your business
and continue to grow so let's look at
social media great pick one
pick one just pick one and crush it
whether it's Twitter or Instagram or
YouTube whatever you think has the best
combination of what you're good at you
know so if you like making videos
YouTube's a great place to be if you
like writing you can go on Twitter or
medium right pick the one platform and
then spend your time focused on that
because if I look at most of people's
content
you look at your own content look at
what you're posting across these
platforms are you proud of it would you
follow you
probably not for too many people so stop
wasting time posting mediocre garbage
and post quality in one spot and start
to win there and then leverage it and
then build a team and then expand same
thing with products and services and
business lines you can't do a great job
servicing your customers investing back
to research Development coming up with
new white you can't you can't not if
you're doing 18 businesses at the same
time
I had a woman come out to my uh Workshop
when I was doing a tour
and this was her issue she was in real
estate and she was in network marketing
and she was in five different business
lines she said well I need to diversify
diversify what you don't have anything
yet you're diversifying yourself out of
a life
out of an income out of a business
where if you just had one super strong
pillar that then won
you'll win now the argument for
diversification is well if one thing
crumbles you got something else great
but here's what people are missing if
YouTube crumbles I'll take my skill set
and go somewhere else if my business
crumbles I'm still me I'll take my skill
set and move somewhere else look at Jake
Paul and Logan Paul they were on Vine
they crushed it on Vine top people on
Vine Vine closes down right almost
overnight closes down great they have a
skill set they come to YouTube and blow
up I get millions of subscribers
if YouTube goes away
for me my skill set is applicable to
wherever people are going to watch video
content next if your business goes away
the skills that you've learned will go
somewhere else
you haven't lost you haven't forgotten
how to do your thing
diversification is only important when
you don't know what you're doing
that's why it's a great investment
strategy because you can't control the
company if if Google starts tanking
because they have some lawsuit you have
no control over that so yes you need to
diversify right at the U.S economy tanks
you should have a diversified portfolio
because you can't control that but when
you can't control it when it's your
business I'm in the I'm in the line of
Andrew Carnegie who was the richest
human on the planet when he was alive
and he said put all your eggs in one
basket and then watch that basket rule
number five the last one before our very
special bonus clip ask for help not
asking for help is selfish you might
think that trying to do everything
yourself is selfless that it's wrong to
ask for help and Noble to do everything
yourself but you love helping people you
love helping others remember that Joy
you feel when you help somebody and
write a smile to their face knowing you
made their week by you not asking for
help you're cheating people of that
opportunity to bring a smile to their
face stop being selfish and start asking
for help I came up with this idea when I
was at a video game Cafe so here's what
happened I was I was on a call with one
of my big customers at the time and I
was in Los Angeles and we're doing a
Google live streaming to my YouTube
channel lots of people watching YouTube
live I'm interviewing him and then the
internet net goes down like what
happened the power went out across all
of Los Angeles the power goes out and it
and it's down I got nothing the stream
is still live but I'm not there anymore
I left my client live on the stream and
he's he's not sure what happens he just
sees my camera goes down and then he
keeps going by himself for another 15-20
minutes waiting for me to come back and
he's he's embarrassed and it's awkward
he doesn't know what he's doing because
the host
who has the audience there is now gone
and then eventually he just leaves
because he said well I don't know where
Evan is but
thank you guys for watching and it put
him in a really difficult situation I
felt terrible I went back to watching
the live stream after like oh my God I
can't believe that happened now it's out
of my control like you know the internet
goes down in Los Angeles what am I
supposed to do there's no power anywhere
so as soon as the power gets back up I
messaged my my client and say hey man
I'm really sorry about that let's
reschedule it let's do it again when I'm
back home in Toronto where I know I have
stable internet and and I want to do it
again for free no extra cost uh even
though we had almost finished the live
stream together we're gonna do a whole
other one for free just because I want
you to I want to make this right for you
great so we come back to Toronto it's
like the a week or two later and my
internet is pretty Rock Solid in my home
office I've never had an internet issue
really happen while I was doing a live
stream but I wanted to make extra sure
extra sure that this time nothing
happened because if something happened
the second time like just it would not
be a good thing so I asked my friend J
rise and I said J rise I need I need a
place that has Rock Solid internet that
I'm gonna do this live stream and
nothing can go wrong
and he said I got a place it's an
internet cafe that got that I go to I'll
introduce you to the owner I know him
and and you can do it there like thank
you so much so we go there I'm there an
hour early I'm setting up I'm talking to
the owner I'm testing the gear my
microphone the headset all of it the
camera testing all of it just to make
sure that everything is working smoothly
I'm nervous because the last time it
failed on us my client comes on we go
live for half an hour an hour I don't
remember and it was smooth perfect no
issues crisp amazing internet blazing
fast speeds great time with the audience
and we delivered an awesome product
sigh of relief right I'm so pumped I go
talk to the owner and say dude thank you
man it was perfect no complaints no
problems thank you so much how much do I
owe you
and he said well you are on the computer
for about an hour and a half and j-rod's
on the computer for about an hour and a
half but I'll just bundle it together so
I think what he told me was like five
bucks or seven bucks or ten bucks or
something like are you kidding me I
would have paid a thousand dollars I
would have paid a lot of money just to
make sure that this went smoothly
because it's the it's the relationship
with my client at the time right
I said okay well let me great here's
here's the seven dollars that you wanted
awesome let me buy let me buy some some
stuff from behind the counter let me buy
some snacks from my friend Jerry Rice
jairo's was hungry he needed to eat so
like here here's 20 bucks 25 bucks let
me just buy out a whole bunch of your
snacks and give it to him he's like no
no you don't have to do that man don't
worry about it like no I want to do it
let me buy the snack no no don't worry
about it
the owner thought that he was doing a
good thing the owner thought
that he was being selfless that hey
don't worry but you don't have to do it
that just just paying for the internet
was enough for him but he was actually
being selfish
in that moment he was being selfish
because he cheated me of the opportunity
of one saying thank you I wanted to pay
more I want to pay more you're cheating
me of the opportunity to do it and
you're cheating me of the opportunity to
help my friend J rise and give him some
food because he was hungry so we had to
go somewhere else you need to be willing
to bring other people in you need to be
willing to ask for help
yes you don't want to waste your time
yes you want to be respectful yes but
people love helping others we are built
to serve you want to help other people
that joy that you feel when you help
somebody out
allow it to come into other people's
hearts too
and it only comes when you open up and
you ask for help and you say hey
I would I'm really struggling with this
thing right now
and and I would I could really use some
help
and people may not be willing to do it
may not have the time to do it
don't be too pushy and don't be too
overwhelming
but don't be selfish at the same time
too so now how do you do it I'm going to
give you a three-step process on how to
ask for help and stop being selfish step
number one is what are you struggling
with right now what are you struggling
with right now well where do you need
help in your business listen
entrepreneurship is rough right you're
wearing all the hats what do you need
the most help with now whether it's
strategy whether it's a new skill set
you need to learn whether it's just
basic whether it's just taking off some
of the the operational stuff that you
have to do in your business right the
day-to-day the the grinds is just
overwhelmed with Project work what do
you need help with number two who is an
expert at that thing who do you know who
have you helped before who's in your
circle who is an expert at that thing
who by them spending a little bit of
time with you you could make a really
big impact on your business make that
list and set number three is reach out
to them with love appreciation and zero
expectations explain the story explain
how much this would mean to you explain
why you're struggling and how you want
to use this thing to get to the next
level in your business in your career in
your mission in your vision and then how
they could be an important part of it
with love
but zero expectations if they say
they're busy don't be hurt by it if they
say sorry I can't help that's okay
but Reach Out
don't take the yes away from them the
problem when you don't reach out is
you're saying no for them
when you don't reach out you're saying
no for them
and a lot of people would want to say
yes to you
burnout is real but I think most burnout
happens because people are not doing the
thing that they actually love doing it's
not just about being busy and keeping
your mind occupied all day you can be
busy and hate your life and get burnt
out if I was an accountant I would hate
my life and burn out in a day because I
don't like being an accountant but doing
this thing that I love I put in way more
effort way more work and I love it it's
been 10 plus years of still having my
YouTube channel and I'm not burnt out if
anything I'm pushing harder than ever
before because I love it and so I think
it's not just about being busy it's
about being busy on the thing that is
your mission for life now compassion
fatigue is a thing doing it so much that
you burn out yourself is possible but
again that is not why most people are
burning out most people I believe are
burning out because they're spending too
much time too much energy too much
effort doing things that they hate and
if you wake up and hate your life and
hate the job you're about to go to then
just no wonder why you feel like you're
burning out so I recently came back from
going to Tony Robbins event in Dallas he
invited me to sit in the front row and
uh super blessed and grateful to have
Tony support and I went there with Alex
friend of the channel who helps me run
trying to dance salsa and we're on a
super crunch timeline because Alex was
teaching classes the the evening before
we left and then the day of the last
event and we we rushed down there Alex
was flying in just to get to the event
he's late on the first day we're rushing
to leave on the last day and it's
non-stop if you if you've been to a Tony
Robbins event it's it's all day all
night it's eight in the morning to
midnight and then up again the next day
and doing the same thing and and it's
wild and it's fun it's amazing and my
favorite thing to do whenever I travel
is actually meet believe Nation meet you
guys and so all through the event I wear
my believe hoodie and I'm not wearing
Grand stuff I'm wearing Evan Carmichael
stuff with the plane and the believe on
the back and people are stopping me and
that's actually the best it doesn't take
away from my experience Tony's often on
stage at the top at the beginning of
every event saying hey I have some
friends of mine you might know them
don't be celebrities leave them alone
don't talk to them let them have their
own experience and it always makes me
sad when he says that because for me
meeting you guys meeting people who
recognize me and that's a group that I
over index because people who watch Tony
videos you know they're probably going
to find my content I like it I like it
more when people come and say hi it adds
to the experience for me and then on the
last day before we rushed out to go to
the airport I set up a meet-up right I
had an hour open before having to get to
the airport so let's do a meet up let's
do a local Dallas Richardson Texas
Meetup right and and it could have spent
the time doing something else or
sleeping in or writing my book or doing
anything else but
it's not burnout for me like that fuels
me that gives me more energy I love it
hanging out with believe Nation gives me
more energy than it takes away and I
then took an Uber to get to my to the
airport and the guy who drove the Uber
was actually in the the Meetup in
Richardson's like I gotta leave early
because I gotta start my job okay great
and then I book an Uber and there he is
a total fluke but amazing and so it's a
lot of work you know I was all day all
night not connecting with my team not
doing the things that I'm supposed to be
doing and I still make time to be with
people and and make a one-hour Meetup
because that hour was open and
it fuels me but if it was something that
I hated just that half an hour just 15
minutes I'd start to feel like I'm
burning out like I don't want to be here
like this is terrible and so I think
it's really important that you're doing
work that you love that would be a
burnout for other people but not a
burnout for you because you love it so
much so how do you find it how do you
find the work that you love I got a
three-step process called who I how I'm
going to talk about it in depth in my
next book but let's do a super quick
analysis here to help you guys who might
be struggling step number one is who so
you're who is your most important core
value what is your most important core
value as a human being
mine is believe it's a one word most
important value for me so when you
figure out what it is that you stand for
as a human you can then look at your
life and see where you're falling short
if you're unhappy with life it's because
you are living incongruently with your
most important core value so someone
whose core value is freedom as an
example
you can look at your life like are you
allowed to be free are you free at work
are you free in your relationships are
you free you know in these different
areas if not then you're not going to be
happy that's why you're not happy
because your boss doesn't allow you to
have freedom mine is believe so believe
has to be in everything that I touch if
there's a situation that's lacking
believe I'm not going to be happy with
it so that just gives you already an
indication of who you are and starts to
make sense of your life going backwards
and allows you to plan it better going
forward so it's one of the most
important exercises I think anybody can
do figure out what your who is who I how
step two is why so why is your purpose
your purpose comes in your pain your
purpose comes from the deepest darkest
most painful moment in your life
whatever that was your purpose is to
help other people who are currently
going through that thing whatever you
struggled with suffered with endured
felt like you never want to wish that on
your worst enemy never want to go back
and experience again that pain that's
what I'm talking about you want to help
other people who are currently going
through that pain because there's a lot
of people who are currently going
through that thing who you were X number
of years ago there's a lot of people who
are currently like that right now that's
who you want to help for Life that'll
never get old that's your purpose for
life I want to help entrepreneurs for
life I believe in entrepreneurs for life
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur and I want to make the path
a little bit easier for everybody else
so that's your wire and your who and
your why are constant they never change
your core values and your purpose are
for life and that's amazing the last
step is how who I how how is your
passion how is how you got out of the
pain that you're in so you struggled
with something how did you get out of it
you may not be fully out of it maybe
you're still on your journey out of it
but you're further ahead than you used
to be how did you get out of it did you
read books did you watch videos did you
meditate did you walk your dogs did you
listen to music like how did you get out
of it how did you get out of it and that
is a recipe that you can teach other
people how you got out of it was not
some random one-off situation you can
teach other people so I struggled a lot
with my business I felt worthless as a
human I wanted to quit I told my partner
that I quit how I got out of it was
modeling success I looked at Bill Gates
how he started Microsoft and I applied
those strategies to my business and we
started to see some success 20 years
later what am I doing still modeling
success right I want to learn from Grant
I want to learn from Steve I want to
learn from Kanye I want to learn from
these people it's why keep creating this
content
how I got out of it was studying success
and now I teach other people how to
study success right how you actually go
about doing it may change when I first
started doing it 20 years ago is through
books right now it's through videos and
in 10 years 20 years is going to be
through VR and a bunch of other
technologies that I'm sure are coming
but
the how you got out is a teachable
recipe that you can give to other people
so if you're struggling with burnout
and you think it's because you don't
love the work that you're doing and you
know that you're destined for something
greater that you do have Michael Jordan
level Talent at something but you don't
know what it is and you want to figure
it out figure it out this is this is the
process this is the easiest process I
know of to get there figure out your who
your one where most important core value
figure out your why your purpose comes
from your pain and figure out your how
which is your passion how you got out of
it you can teach other people and that
will set you up for an amazing life with
hopefully very little burnout and
definitely a lot of purpose
[Music]
yo I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome and if you
want to watch Evan's top 10 rules for
Success check out the video next to me I
think you can enjoy continue typically I
will see you there if you're not happy
it's because you're not serving either
serving the world or serving the the
closest people to you but if you're not
happy it's because you're not serving
and so I want to help other people who
are struggling with belief like I was